[Music]
on this Friday night Judgment Day for
the feds was using the emergencies act
Justified the very high threshold
required for the invocation of the ACT
was met the inquiry's recommendations
plus the conclusions about the Ontario
government's role
This Is How It Ends the final day in
office for disgraced Toronto mayor John
Tory
no more parents and no more home the
plight of the youngest earthquake
survivors now orphaned
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
after weeks of hearings and hours of
witness testimony an inquiry has found
prime minister Justin Trudeau's
government made the right decision
invoking the emergencies act during last
Winter's Convoy protests using the
controversial powers for the first time
in Canadian history
what began as a massive protest
evolved into something entirely
unprecedented when the decision was made
to invoke the act on February 14 2022
cabinet had reasonable grounds to
believe
that there existed a national emergency
Justice Rulo says he made his decision
reluctantly blaming both government
leaders and police for not acting sooner
our chief political correspondent David
Aiken has been sifting through the
hundreds of pages in the report and he
begins our coverage tonight David let's
start with how we got here yeah well
that the commissioning commissioner you
just heard he's retired Ontario judge
Justice Paul roulo and he says it's
pretty clear to him how the emergency
started the response to the freedom
Convoy included a series of policing
failures make no mistake it was chaotic
it was lawless in downtown Ottawa and
the the residents of Ottawa were afraid
and no one was helping them
but Rulo also concluded that Ontario
Premier Doug Ford and his government
share some blame that they were too slow
to respond and essentially abandoned
Ottawa to the Convoy preparing for and
responding to situations of threat
and urgency in a federal system requires
governments at all levels
and those who lead them to rise above
above politics and collaborate for the
common good
and so by the middle of February last
year prime minister Justin Trudeau and
his cabinet concluded they had to invoke
the never before used emergencies act we
didn't want to have to invoke the
emergencies Act
it's a measure of Last Resort roulette
did not find fault with that decision
cabinet had reasonable grounds to
believe
that there existed a national emergency
arising from threats to the security of
Canada
that necessitated The Taking of special
temporary measures
those temporary measures included
prohibitions on assembly making it
illegal to give food fuel supplies or
money to protesters compelling tow truck
drivers to assist police and most
controversially allowing the RCMP to
freeze the bank accounts of protesters
the measures taken by the federal
government were for the most part
appropriate and effective
rullo found lots of things to improve
his 2000 page report includes 56
recommendations and 27 of those are
about policing he called for overhauls
of Provincial Police acts improved
intelligence sharing new protocols for
forces that find themselves overwhelmed
by major events and much more Rulo also
said disinformation campaigns on social
media requires study by all levels of
government the federal government he
says needs to do more to understand
cryptocurrencies and the 35 year old
emergencies act itself needs an overhaul
there are lessons for everyone involved
law enforcement agencies all orders of
government and elected officials
and a federal and provincial governments
do act on rullo's recommendation then
one day police forces should have the
resources in the training to prevent
future events like the Convoy protest
governments will have systems in place
to cooperate and tools to use so that no
one ever has to invoke the emergencies
act ever again now that is a tall order
but roulo believes he's created the
blueprint that governments should use as
a start all right David let's talk more
now about the political Fallout from all
this this afternoon we heard from both
the Prime Minister and the opposition
leader so where does it go from here
well first of all you know the Liberals
cannot be more pleased with Rolo's
assessment because he found the Trudeau
government acted within the law
appropriate temporary measures uh if any
politician took heat formula was
actually Ontario's Doug Ford now the
Trudeau liberals they would like to
continue to try to tie Pierre pauliev to
the more unsavory elements of the Convoy
protest but pauliev today he turned the
emergency back on Trudeau this was an
emergency that Justin Trudeau created by
attacking his own population by driving
up their cost of living
you know in far out no commission is
going to settle that argument
it's one we're going to keep hearing
until there's the next election David
Aiken and Ottawa thank you David from
federal to local politics in Canada's
largest city when John Tory was elected
mayor of Toronto more than eight years
ago he promised an end to the sideshow
that City Hall had become
they are going to have more confidence
in one city in one Toronto in the
government of the city in the entire
Council of the city and that is my
objective
for the most part that worked
International media lost interest in
Toronto City Hall and it was generally
back to business until a week ago less
than an hour after a bombshell report
from the Toronto Star revealed Tori had
a relationship with the junior staffer
he announced his intention to step down
and today is Mike drolets that
resignation became official
this is how the last day of John Tory's
time as mayor began
alone Cowboys strolled up to Toronto
City Hall at roughly 6 20 a.m before
hurling four eggs at the office windows
two hit two went astray and then he
calmly walked away how come you did that
Tori for his part barely glanced up from
his paper on the day he officially
resigned the Tory era may be over but
easy isn't the way it ended he ends on
it on a rather
yeah not an exciting note but that and
that's the way he came into office
uh he promised not to do much and he
didn't so I should probably wash my
hands for his first two terms in office
Tori embodied the straight-laced
button-down conservative Persona he
promised what did you stop following the
Scandal plague circus of his predecessor
Rob Ford he's done taking questions
but last week it all came crashing down
during the pandemic I developed a
relationship with an employee the
consensual Affair which he says began
early in the pandemic with a 31 year old
staffer ended only recently what's still
unclear as if the mayor's office was
compromised by the relationship and that
may never be known I suspect uh this
this pretty much shuts down certainly
any any uh institutional city interest
in looking into this further he's no
longer mayor his legacy is certainly
impacted both as the squeaky clean mayor
and devout family man when he first came
into office he promised to keep tax is
low but that's come at the expense of
affordable housing and crumbling
infrastructure what do I want to be
remembered for
I know my departure and its
circumstances will rank high on some
lists but I do hope that in time other
things will stand out
that we are finally back to building
Transit now taxpayers will have to spend
Millions on a by-election to replace
their fiscally prudent mayor after
nominations and a short campaign the
mayor's office should have a new tenant
by late spring Mike drill like Global
News Toronto
to the U.S now where the five former
Memphis police officers accused of
killing Tyree Nichols have pleaded not
guilty to criminal charges their
arraignment today comes over a month
after police and traffic cameras capture
the suspects brutally beating the 29
year old black man after a traffic stop
the five officers each face charges of
second-degree murder aggravated assault
aggravated kidnapping official
misconduct and official oppression
members of Nichols family sat in the
back of the courtroom his mother says
she will be at every court date until
she gets Justice for her son
I want each and every one of those
police officers
to be able to look me in the face they
they haven't done that yet they couldn't
even do that today they didn't even have
the courage to look at me in my face
after what they did to my son
Nichols was repeatedly punched and
kicked on January 7th he was
hospitalized and he died three days
later
residents of an Ohio town are outraged
about the potential harmful aftermath of
a trained derailment earlier this month
even though the state's Governor says
there is no evidence of increased
toxicity so far
nothing from the train derailment was
found in the homes nothing was found out
on the street the monitoring will
continue however
State officials say there is no evidence
of contaminants after more than 500
homes were tested residents who use
Municipal Water have also been told they
don't have to drink bottled water the
only contamination involves a Waterway
near the crash site that officials are
confident the damage is contained two
people have been killed in an avalanche
near Golden British Columbia bringing
the number of avalanche deaths in the
province to nine so far this year and
this is Family Day weekend so experts
are warning of increased danger as more
people head into the back country
we're recommending people
um really uh take a take the extra time
to think about you know how big of an
avalanche a particular piece of terrain
could produce and try and reduce their
overall Risk by exposing less people at
a time to uh to Any Given slopes
Avalanche Canada is comparing this
season's snowpack with conditions seen
in the winter of 2002-2003 that's when
more than two dozen people died in
Avalanches making it one of BC's Worst
Years ever for fatalities
new miracles in the earthquake zone
coming up those finally found after
being trapped for more than a week and a
half
protests in cities across Iran flared up
overnight in the most widespread
anti-government demonstrations in weeks
videos posted online show protesters
marching through the streets chanting
women life freedom and calling for the
overthrow of the Islamic Republic the
March is marked 40 days since the
execution of two men on charges related
to the ongoing protests for five months
there have been demonstrations right
across the country after the death of 22
year old Masa amini while she was
detained by Iran's morality police for
violating the country's strict hijab
policy
Marketing
in Karachi Pakistan gunfire and multiple
explosions as armed men stormed a police
station three police officers and a
civilian were killed 11 others were
injured before police regained control
Pakistan's Taliban has claimed
responsibility for the attack the
country has seen a surge in militant
attacks since the Taliban ended a
month-long ceasefire with the government
in November in Turkey incredibly
survivors are still being pulled from
the rubble 11 days after those
devastating earthquakes
rescue teams pulled three people alive
from undercollapsed buildings today
including this man in his 40s last week
two powerful earthquakes struck turkey
and Syria killing more than 43 thousand
people and leaving Millions homeless
moths across the two countries performed
absentee funeral prayers for the dead as
many could not receive full burial
rights because of the enormity of the
disaster
and humanitarian organizations say
millions of children who are living in
the earthquake zone right now are in
urgent need of humanitarian support as
Ross Lord reports they may have survived
the disaster but their future is far
from a certain
as the only earthquake Survivor in her
family nine-year-old fatmaisa is forced
to live with memories no child should
have to endure
she recalls being covered in rocks along
with other family members in Syria and
it taking an hour to get her leg out
from beneath the rubble Fatma is among
an estimated 7 million children affected
by the Quakes thousands are feared dead
many others like Fatma are orphaned the
desperate effort to provide food and
warmth the U.N world food program says
it's fed two hundred thousand survivors
in Syria so we anticipate there's
probably double that number that are
still needing to get assistance and
we're desperately trying to get them
assistance among the priorities
providing safe drinking water and
sanitation to prevent the spread of
diseases in addition to life-saving
Essentials UNICEF says it's working to
provide play spaces for children in
Syria and in Turkey children are very
resilient but with freezing cold a child
left under on his own knees or her own
is a truth of their life another
priority reuniting children who've been
separated from their families something
UNICEF in Turkey says has so far had
only some success we have identified at
least 1 600 children who have been
separated from their remedies and at
least almost 1 000 of them we have
managed to record to uh to really
reunite them with their with their
families
for children who no longer have any
family at all like three-year-old tarek
Haider the future is anyone's guess
his nurse says tariq's mother and father
were pulled out before he was rescued
but they did not survive
the vulnerability of the orphans is
astounding this baby girl Aya was born
under Rubble in Syria the hospital
caring for Aya almost lost her to a
group of gunmen trying to kidnap her her
doctor says she's been under police
guard since several other people showed
up falsely claiming they're related to
her from a world away such desperation
is hard to comprehend for the youngest
Children Of This Disaster it may be all
they know
Ross Lord Global News
[Music]
protectionists pledge ahead why Joe
Biden's bold economic strategy has the
Canadian government concerned
[Music]
during his State of the Union Address
U.S President Joe Biden committed to
implementing tougher by American
policies ensuring American
infrastructure will be made with
American Products as Mackenzie gray
explains the strategy could jeopardize
billions of dollars for Canadian
businesses
but their words every Canadian
government hates to hear we're going to
buy American we're going to buy America
that protectionist pledge was one of the
few moments that U.S President Joe Biden
received bipartisan support during the
State of the Union on my watch American
roads Bridges American highways are
going to be made with American Products
as well but Biden isn't the only U.S
politician who's pushed this platform we
will follow two Simple Rules by American
and hire American it's a rare issue that
Trump Biden and the majority of the
American people all agree on
recent polls showed that 75 percent of
Democrats and 60 percent of Republicans
support increase by America policies
Biden's plan would freeze out Canadian
companies from bidding on U.S federal
government contracts which spells bad
news for the Canadian economy there's
eight billion dollars in cross-border
trade of lumber 17 billion for steel and
half a billion in Asphalt contracts all
in Jeopardy if Biden tightens trade
rules and that's the disappointing thing
I think Canadians expected When Donald
Trump left office that we'd see a very
different approach being taken by a new
Administration instead what we're seeing
is President Biden doubling down on a
number of the measures that Donald Trump
put in place the goal of the policy to
try and bring more jobs back to the U.S
and increase manufacturing but many
economists say it actually drives up
costs if you're looking at it from a
consumer welfare perspective at least
consumers uh worse off the Canadian
government plans to Lobby members of
Congress who have closed business ties
with Canada to try and put pressure on
the administration this is an issue that
is a top priority for me and we're going
to keep working on this the US federal
government is currently studying how to
implement the Biden by America policies
and that gives the Liberals some time to
try and carve out a Canadian exemption
with the U.S Administration
pharah Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you Mackenzie and that's global national
for this Friday night I'm Farah Nasser
on behalf of our whole crew I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your Friday evening with us tonight's
your Canada is the hot air balloon event
in Vernon British Columbia until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night
[Music]